hello strange person who I have never
met before who are you I'm Janet
snake-hole I'm a very rich widow with a
terrible secret who are you
Bert Macklin FBI was the best damn age
they had until I was framed for a crime
I didn't commit
stealing the president's rubies now I
work alone lovely to meet you I got to
admit I thought your costume would maybe
be a little bit [ __ ] er thanks
gentlemen spawn song how you livin yes
why don't you own the snake juice I'm
more of a whiskey man
Ron Ron come here come here for a bit
you're good right there listen you gotta
jump on the Tommy Tom Express this guy
is some of the best investment ideas
I've ever heard in my life make a baby
tuxedo clothing line a department store
with the guestlist white fur earmuffs
for men contact lenses that display text
messages embed a phone that smells good
own a nightclub called Eclipse that's
only open for one hour two times a year
cover charge $5,000 I can keep going
how about this runt try snake juice if
you like it you got to talk it up all
night
if you don't I'll shave jean-ralphio
head
yeah I'd like to see that hit me lot
riding on this
[Music]
damn if that isn't delicious are to the
ODE to the end then desist once got
swagging the size a Big Ben clock you
gotta end it on the ride know what I
have had it I got it you think I haven't
been around the world it's been
everywhere darling I'm a very wealthy
woman my husband's kept me in the finest
clothes from Bergdorf Goodman's freeze
FBI kill anybody and I didn't burn down
the middle aged my sister but now she
been aided by walls nothing to see here
hello my name is Ron Swanson in general
I try never to speak with people but I
have been drinking this snake juice
thing and it's damn good you should buy
it okay thanks man son you should know
that my recommendation is essentially a
guarantee drink this now no offense dude
I remember you having a nursing degree
in feelings offense that's rude I'm
gonna go dance do sure uh well are you
okay
I heard yelling yeah I'm very angry and
I'm really drunk do you wanna dance with
me go get me now two snork juice oh
that's that's maybe not the best idea
for you forget it John Ralphie oh yes
I'm here
dance upon me yes yes yes every time I
cleanse I can literally feel the toxins
leaving my body I know I feel so much
healthier
I've still got a full week to go before
the broth stage hmm
free broth is an amazing stage it's when
you're most alert good someone needs to
be alert tonight this snake juice is
basically a rat poison everybody's
wasted you don't even know what think I
didn't even say what they get it she
asked me the whole thing and I'd even do
it once I'm like a Nelson okay if I walk
into a room it's like okay he's in there
bababooey turns music down father
[Music]
instead of putting the YC [ __ ] I feel
phenomenal yeah
you come into me Kenneth and I protected
then we got in the role-playing in the
only the momma no my buddies don't
trophy class she write the B is this
everybody and took a cab
Tom to the trunk Jerry's on the roof all
right we're to first you mouse but if
even one of you thinks about drying even
in my car you're all walking home
Leslie I'm here we have to go hire a new
PR director for the health department oh
my god I'm so hungover I've never been
this hour I feel great I ran 5k this
morning oh no I
you